standing in line for Frederick the Great
and his lovely little palace guided
tours start here every five minutes in
the summer there's a lot of demand and
if you don't book online or get up early
you won't get in Frederick was an early
riser too he was a hard worker
disciplined a Prussian
through-and-through but he also had a
cultural side he was a musician and
philosopher they say you can't get
closer to Frederick the Great than in
sanssouci it's the most personal of his
palaces
the palace graces the hillside on which
it was built
the nearby windmill was already here in
1743 when king frederick and his court
stopped here for a break this idyllic
landscape pleased the young monarch and
he decided to build his new summer
palace here frederick sketched out his
ideas to his architect hans gieok
wenceslaus Funke mumbled stove a large
entrance a small palace and a terraced
vineyard noble stove objected no BUTT
STUFF I know goes dog believed from the
start that the palace needed another
floor to make it higher and more
imposing but frederick insisted he
wanted to be able to walk straight out
into the garden no straightening up the
King got his way and only one floor was
built the Rococo style building has only
12 rooms back then as now visitors enter
the palace through the lobby and that
leads to the marble hole the main
reception hall but there were no lively
bowls here women were not welcome at the
palace but Frederick did invite leading
intellectuals for his legendary
roundtable discussions Voltaire the
leading mind of the French enlightenment
was a frequent guest here
Fredrik loves spending time in his
library he had more than 2,000 books not
one of them was in German his mastery of
the language was inadequate French was
the language of the royal court
sanssouci is a much more intimate
building than the baroque palaces that
other monarchs were building at the time
are today or not was in the 18th century
what impressed people was the palaces
comparative modesty that this great war
hero should live so simply they were
also impressed that there were no guards
within limits it was a public building
people could look through the windows or
walk through the garden this was in
stark contrast to other
eighteenth-century courts maybe visitors
back then would have seen the king
playing his flute in his music room he
practiced every day he also composed
symphonies and other pieces which were
performed by small chamber orchestras
Frederick on the flute Carl Philipp
Emanuel Bach on the harpsichord
frederik dedicated himself to music and
philosophy while at sanssouci he spent
almost 40 summers here from April to
October but he never did see the great
fountains working his gardeners were
unable to master the technology
otherwise he had reason to be pleased
with the gardens with the flowers and
the fruits and vegetables Houston in
taxes pure honey there used to be apple
and pear trees where the trend you trees
are now and there were real walnut and
sweet chestnut trees next to the
vineyard there were pine apples and
strawberries and as you can see behind
me the vines and figs were behind glass
so that the fruit could be harvested
earlier enough we as its design wish to
add it's okay Frederick only grew grapes
for eating he preferred drinking French
wine there were no potatoes either he
ordered them to be grown in the Prussian
countryside but they did not end up on
his table
in 1786 Frederic died his final wish was
not granted until more than 200 years
later in 1991 he was reburied together
with his 11 greyhounds on the terrace at
the foot of his beloved palace